citizens of the reject Nation it is time to
watch the Justice League fight the Teen Titans
if you want to see an entire league beat up
some kids you're in the right place very excited
to watch this with John who as per tradition
also hasn't seen it that's true I'm holding
strong koi I haven't broken yet you're secretly
watching these like right before
Justice League very very big villains of the
Titans right man uh speaking of villainy we
will be at WonderCon probably this Sunday
because it is actually the Sunday this Sunday
you won't see us next Sunday no no I don't
see anybody next Sunday Sunday the 26th at
11 A.M you'll see us and Greg who will be
there talking about the state of Marvel the
state of DC the state of the industry and
we want some fan interactivity so be there
for more Rhymes uh also please do like and
subscribe on this video before you go to WonderCon
leave a comment let us know which of these
videos you've enjoyed which ones you want
us to watch next when you want us to get to
the ranking that's inevitably Gonna Come What
do we do because there's a lot of these most
of all I'd like to think
oh this G fuel is the boys and not only is
it the boys but it's actually compound V so
uh you're gonna be sprouting powers oh and
if you would like compound VG fuel or any
of the G fuels Link in the box below get a
little description box you can click your
link there and then you can have the focus
of Solomon the wisdom of all the things that
I forgot from that movie that I enjoyed more
than most and the promo code reject nation
is it reject Nation reject Nation there it
is that's all the data you need if you're
a super sexy reject and you've earned patreon
you get front to back whole way through without
pause resting faces but without further ado
let's fight some Titans
already better music than a lot of Pop right
now oh was that Raven I don't know she is
a Teen Titan reporting live from the site
of a massive battle between the Justice League
and a group of what can only be described
as super villains calling themselves the Legion
of Doom sounds like sounds like super villains
at the unveiling of their new headquarters
stepped by many on social media as the Hall
of Justice that's who they bought back black
suit Superman oh yeah it's Gotta Stay okay
oh so we're definitely back in continuity
because these outfits hey Kristen wig s [Music]
hard to fight that ever seen Barry do the
arms yeah that's great I've seen in the comics
I didn't I haven't seen it in movie is this
any way to treat your guest Superman seeing
as how you crash the party I'd consider us
even
[Music] come on Diana what happened this guy
cyborg yeah you're gonna take that from a
drone my man born on a man
made him say smash like the Hulk
just watches
oh Robin report how's crowd control
[Laughter] addicted they respond like contemptible
sheep oh man that's who I I like Damien the
crisis I do too like people don't but I like
them
oh
[Laughter] I'm simply an innocent industrialist
caught in the middle I'll bet
all those innocent industrialists wow that
Old Chestnut [Laughter]
[Music] let's go be so cool man I'm sitting
there The Flash movie like uh here they are
like I'm so excited to see stuff like this
no Tom Cruise loves it it's good I mean it's
gonna be a perfect film yeah top gun Maverick
of the year
not in the face whatever you say
Jesus
that's your new uniform right there I like
it
[Music] do you know how hard it is to find
a replacement power glove in this day and
age
nice use of face
running from The Flash whoa [Music]
come on Wizard don't make me hit you with
you again whoa jeez the hour of his Rising
is at hand I've got this probably for the
best speaking of the child oh no oh
nobody makes me bleed my own blood
he's not using any Tech it's magic I mean
any Tech is sufficiently Advanced as indistinguishable
for magic so don't tell that to Superman because
then he's immune to not just Tech oh man get
them to safety I'll keep him distracted comment
cover
s [Music] sometimes gotta spanking out of
the car
oh no I'm being underutilized no you're worth
boy Target locked Damien Stand Down late now
get up there bats [Music]
[Applause]
[Music] it's the end of Dark Knight Rises
but a little different retconned
it's a lot of dead fish I know the the atlanteans
are going to be pissed again
damn looks like an anime creature yeah it
did what we have is an empty shell with no
answers if you had followed orders and done
what you're told we'd know more come on cut
him some slack at least he was trying to foreign
not that I disagree it's about teamwork all
I see is a lot of ineffectual grandstanding
which is why I prefer to work alone and my
dad thinks I'm difficult have you ever considered
boarding school
peanut gallery well the baby just makes everyone
uncomfortable like everyone's just like oh
why it's Batman you're you're really gonna
step to me right now um Batman thank you
stunt you pulled hey every time we're gonna
lose it when he comes to live action because
I get excited every time he's the MVP of all
of these truly teammates are a liability then
what am I to you an unavoidable irritation
sure a rash oh Teen Titans are coming back
big in the comics right now and it's really
exciting through a Nightwing comic ooh Now's
the Time hop on people maybe I'll start reading
something the Nightwing run is I think the
best Nightwing's ever been right now ever
Danger Room sequence activate VR Missions
you were having a nightmare last night I was
just wondering if everything's look I appreciate
your concern I guess but they're Dreams Just
streams glad that's over you know you're naked
right huh [Music] so what animals are naked
I'm the entire Animal Kingdom crammed into
a single magnificent specimen or something
oh it was just laughing at you well but out
bug
I'll talk to Blue Beetle that way in maybe
few Jaime's spine but it's not exactly under
a burn it's Blue Beetle July I thought so
but I don't know now has it moved again Justice
for solo I think sholo's blue beetles like
DC's next big like needs to make a statement
Nightwing Starfire it's been a while Nightwing
MVP the new Robin Welcome Damien
I'll be in my room would you like to I think
I can manage that is boarding school more
like sad oh stand him you are also born in
the darkness just you and me no Men in Tights
that sounds nice by the way I bought some
new glasses you might not recognize me you
both won't recognize each other mysterious
Duo of the spectacled folk I would so love
that they try to go on a day they completely
miss each other
enjoying these horror movie flourishing Frank
you're screwing with the wrong guy he's got
a point yeah like the James Wan elements of
uh the live action movies yeah assistant
oh it's good good good
he hasn't stopped for an hour and a half great
cardio time to let others have turn
I'm not gonna stop until the machine literally
cannot produce any more in pieces
whoa I am the leader of this group as I see
it you're an alien with nowhere else to go
everyone needs a home Damien you included
thank you for chiming in which girl I'm here
to help you realize your potential you've
been here long enough when do you think you'll
realize yours ouch dude dude you need to show
some respect a second I thought he was gonna
say you need to shut up deservedly
yeah let's go training stop this
now this is how they'll learn to respect one
another through the sword
[Applause]
that's the difference between you and me you
wear a weapon I am a weapon that's a bar oh
just cook Robin yep
is he dead [Music] he's still alive oh barely
oh this is going to be an awkward call to
Batman yeah turn your son into freaking two
phase [Music]
[Music]
oh Raven healed you we have to tend to her
sorry I cooked your freaking head you're half
Freddy Krueger you're better now yeah I thought
you might be hungry
no thanks learn from the turtles and he folds
it in half that's oh man Batman does he gotta
earn it though absolutely after a team up
not before what is that a shadow no the sun
direction is wrong and look here it's disconnected
from the surface it's mimicking a shadow it's
wandering like it's looking for something
or someone there's where where the wizard
ran into it more like stepped in it oh see
teamwork good detective work the female leads
seem to only be present in order to be rescued
by the leading man but all in all I find myself
reasonably diverted
averted
oh I've got a lot on my mind right now you
can always share your burdens with me Clark
stay away from me dude put your glasses back
on someone's gonna notice you run around the
street Superman T14 or team or any meanings
that's where the team lives mother Spirit
of another realm protect my brothers and sister
and give me strength to face the dark force
I fear is coming I like her music yeah it's
a Vibe I suppose I should thank you for healing
me um you're welcome [Music] I was groomed
for a higher calling my grandfather I know
all about your grandfather I felt him he was
a demon he was a great man we were going to
make the world stronger I know all about that
game too I don't mean to be rude but would
you mind getting the hell away from me
okay I like them together I could see things
about you too it looked like a man but something
more you have other things to fix here just
stay away from me well you know the secret
though he's bad at thank you he is perhaps
it was a mistake to challenge you this morning
without knowing the full capacity of your
alien attachment
it won't happen again this meeting did he
just say he's sorry it probably has respect
for you now that you you know
that's the way you earn it with them I mean
In fairness oh no oh damn oh this is so cool
this is not what I was expecting at all this
movie
this is how you humanize Superman sure dark
magic
this is how you get an injustice gods amongst
us it's coming Atomic Skull I've got a lot
stronger
that's not good you don't look so good
jeez
it's the Snyder cut yeah [Music]
[Applause] Batman knows absolutely he's barely
alive Clark what's wrong with you
oh the rising is coming you cannot stop it
oh you have your part to play the good will
be girl why did you say that day my mother's
name was Raven Martha with any luck military
satellites are tracking him now and what will
we do wait for him to pull the moon from the
sky but will they do there's military he hasn't
said anything about doing something like that
has he
you tell me if he did right because that sounds
dangerous get back to that island of yours
and lock yourself in the darkest deepest tomb
you can find you can't expect me to hide was
worth a shot I like the part of this teamwork
is knowing when your partners are not gonna
go with your plans tactical just kind of accepting
that but try yeah we didn't know anything
about Raven when we took her in except that
she needed a home I was taught that knowledge
was power and nothing about her you have to
have a little faith sometimes faith is belief
based on an absence of data it invites disaster
I would love to see Damon Damon Damon Christmas
party you have no idea how frustrating it
is he reminds me of my sister
training to kill
Shameless detail Shameless they took time
to animate them oh and like frame by Shameless
field room looks great
that's what we need what [Laughter] that's
who I was thinking at the time and stinking
with you uh you know and then now she's got
a solution oh boy now are your search results
of Superman sightings and to recent Supernatural
events subsection female dude you're gonna
find so many like real ghosts caught on camera
video very creepy you don't want to see that
corner of the internet cyborg you're just
gonna be on slapped ham all night
per tune sand worms [Music] that's where I
left his change sure flip it drop this in
the sand a few years ago tonight mandatory
foot Weird Al
it just leaves on the back seat just propped
up
CW era
anguish oh come on hold hands also like this
hip teenager music yes the kids listen to
yeah pop punk Machine Gun Kelly brought it
back
what ah [Applause] goes right to your thighs
Damien so much cotton candy bro
[Laughter] that's gotta be enough for a big
ass prize he's gotta give it to her
oh
it's it's sting oh Bilbo's sword
oh that's precious she only had four tickets
and she gave him the little 300 tickets sword
Damien without altruism months that tastes
like pure sugar boy were you up in those mountains
a long time yeah I bet he'd hate candy you
may be insufferable but in your heart you
are a Kind and Generous soul
why did you say those Concepts
we must dance dance our hearts out they're
like taking time for World building in this
one yeah like character development's happening
and like not a fight please there's no autographs
I'm a busy man nah Damian's gonna Step Up
dance
okay I know how to Revolution and then he
starts an actual Revolution based off his
dancing using those symbols yeah hope you're
a good loser we've seen he's not nope over
and over you gotta know you witnessed that
he's gonna murder you
hand foot coordination Damian's a different
job
quick study
are those Shazam lightning bolts now they
are yeah look at them go
hmm oh no happiness not now they're waiting
for you buy Zola 2000 spare chain Watson bothering
you go chase her into The Amalgamated Universe
ah not the move on the hill beyond the tent
[Music]
you're part of a team Raven they're right
behind you remember your training this whole
exercise is about
him it's a trick it is me child
oh oh no it's our destiny to be together Raven
always ooh you're an Abomination girl
Abomination Marvel so many crossovers
no glory Trigon [Music] oh mother of Azeroth
give me strength
ooh we will last long enough
Teen Titans part of a team yeah see these
guys work as a team they're over there dancing
no oh no not the rail what if I'm a cow years
of training as a ninja has prepared as cardio
for this very battle awesome dude yes quite
impressive
whatever
seems important to check in on [Music] Titans
Go yeah there's like an anime
sometimes the animation team just make some
choices oh yes hey I I want to feel this good
getting in any outfit yeah
if only clothes could do such things
stylistic one yeah
Damien just not in that Montage I know I guess
it's not a Titan he just puffed his turtleneck
collar up and he's ready to go the Demonic
emissaries my father said your father Steve
Jobs powers activate I always gotta get the
sword
oh
come on Damien
that's right no [Music] no yeah please tell
me they're Undead yes he's been working on
the murders my dad's gonna be pissed
oh dude Damon could probably let off so much
steam with these guys it's just like the training
Danger Room yeah
so do they possess the whole Justice League
thing is that why they're about to versus
I guess maybe yeah it's a good call I just
thought of the title of the movie and our
only hope is these kids yeah Titans Go these
teens
I like the little Jitter effect too it's good
sound design too
yes yes sometimes you gotta go kangaroo
[Music] oh I respect it is gonna remember
that in the morning
[Music] Robin said I didn't know enough about
you oh what I said is that he's gone that's
not the same as dead he's dead to me why is
he trying to kill you he's not trying to kill
me it's much worse trying to give me a hug
forever never let me go I guess it starts
with my mom they decided to do the classic
bride of Satan right and guess who got to
be the lucky bride I doubt anyone expected
it to work with ancient ceremony turned out
to be the real thing hey when that happens
hey everyone's like oh [__] I couldn't
plan for this I tried this before
wow
I'll text didn't hesitate to hook up with
the guy who emerged from the smoke I mean
this is a Vibe I gotta say I like I like this
Christopher Lambert just swings in four eyes
we need more DC romance novels so your mom
did it with Satan
I must have inherited my mom's terrible judgment
because I thought if I found out more about
the monster who made me I'd be able to make
sense of myself it's not a bad call all right
[__]
that is home
wow oh no oh
Buzz for Cusco couscous poison before he could
use me I was able to trap him inside a crystal
why didn't you go back to Azeroth this is
Azeroth
[Music] that is a that is a beautiful painting
though as my new yeah their storyline's great
I mean I did not expect it to be cool but
this is this is really cool you have no idea
what he's like Damien you've never met a monster
like Trigon you beat him once my dad's a demon
if we can't save one of our own who can we
save I thought you hated us I'm not wishing
you dead anymore Robin's right progress that's
how Robin says I love you I don't wear stuff
on you anymore her father's an interdimensional
demon we can protect her
he knows they're here he wants them here who
if they stay everything will be lost this
is is our job father you have to leave father
too late they're here yes out from the Shadows
oh getting symbiated go it's a nerve toxic
for pain
oh the captainian has Unearthed The Infernal
Shrine raided the hood to the what
that's me you are the shrine's final piece
yeah challenge us
[Music]
cool Power it's like anamorphous yeah [Music]
Andy brought his suit today it's Sprite I
mean naked in front of everyone
jeez never pair up with your similar you have
to change villains yeah it's like fighting
Pokemon yeah you always go with different
type beatle
oh
that looks so painful I stopped my hand for
an instant and this one dies too I'll go has
the daughter of your lord Trigon I order you
to release these feeble humans oh boy I hope
nobody else is in the Teen Titans building
yeah they don't have employees right oh good
they saved one get him inside do you think
when the youngest of them turns 18 they have
to remodel the T into an a [Laughter] or like
a g like for grown-ups Titans adult title
adult Titans Go on a pedestal Stargate
a deadish girl we were meant to be together
it's really cool the way they realize the
Magic in this movie yeah a little Tech feel
yeah and like the yeah the circles and the
sort of like symmetry of it all this one's
made me so much more excited for a Teen Titans
movie sure like this is so cool oh cool oh
she's in the Middle East 60 miles north of
Canada City Canada I put a tracer on her when
about 30 seconds after we met in time I put
one on each of you what you guys barely held
your own against Flash and Wonder Woman and
that's without Superman being on Deck he shouldn't
be a problem [Music] got a way to take out
super weird versus Superman uh let me hear
for it let's do it so like the only time he's
not grimacing is when he's smiling like I
love The Duality of David yeah
cool use of Animation too with like static
to add like texture to certain stuff yeah
totally Titans Go do they always say that
a lot okay it's great
they walk that cheesy line beautifully I love
Teen Titans
[Music] you gotta go right for the big gun
first he gonna remember that 'd be great there
it is remember that yeah oh
his Instinct was to Stave him even as he was
dying
you mind removing that
facility cool
[Music] foreign
[Music]
[Laughter] yes [Music]
yes it was really smart how they broke up
the team so like it's not Teen Titans fighting
Wonder Woman because that's ridiculous like
using Superman like this she doesn't belong
to you devil
oh Superman lasso of Truth yeah let me go
you alien pill
it's time for some uncomfortable truths gotta
ask question soups who are you lasso commands
you answer
I am Diana of the mascara
nicely done
it's okay I've got you now just like in the
movies now let's both put our glasses on who
are we
you can get off my back now boy phony ass
squads Damien come on now nothing is right
oh Justice League and Teen Titans versus demons
yeah Trigon special
[Music] Tim Curry and Legend action that's
right
[Music] it's a big boy about a big boom Raven
has a plan Titans need my help oh I'm going
to hell yes yes do this I'm going to hell
so metal the crystal can only be touched by
me he may have escaped it but he can't destroy
it I just hope you left a trail of breadcrumbs
of death blood crumbs skull maggots over here
yeah
no
I think it likes that yeah the sudden urge
to play Doom [Music] not great
[Music] what the hell
is he possessed is it because he's in hell
is it the animals there yeah does he have
access to new hell animals I think that would
make some sense that's what I demand for my
Comics continuity Comics are known for him
plausibility
[Music]
yeah demon Beast Boy
gar you still with us
Shaka you might not be able to talk but he
can still be a teenager yeah
[Music] come on up his butt like Thanos take
him out right then tickled you sneeze on him
no yeah yeah that's that's not great you're
still flashed though all right now we go up
his butt yeah Plan B Plan B for butt
I know I know I I have to do it I'm Superman
this is a problem
[Music]
Goblin Beast Boy [Music] was made of like
flesh and teeth yeah it's gross
too much it's a lot of tumors there's a lot
of tumors Hydra tubers who is your daddy and
what does it do oh
tie the heads together or something
get it Raven
mine work on those oh
thank you [Music] damn Damian my blood it's
a trick I saw you die no trick you're in Hell
bro he can give us the world we wanted you
and I she's the only one who stands in the
way prove your love grandson take care of
this for me of course of course are you afraid
to do the one act that will restore Me to
Life have you forgotten your heritage you
are an Al Gore I'm a Titan yeah yeah buddy
do anything for love but I won't do that you
think your allies can stop me now that I'm
here oh no he's out there attack on tightening
yeah seriously attack on Teen Titans my only
weakness was loving you but all you were capable
of giving was pain friends who give me love
and the strength to do this no reconnect raccoon
now you've got a smaller house yes if you
do this one more time it's gonna be even smaller
frankly studio apartment New York closet
[Music]
nah dude there it is oh is that is that weakness
oh
oh yeah [Music] sustenance turn the demon
Trigon within the sacred shot now forever
so the first time did she just say now and
like for a while now and for a bit we might
got to talk father daughter stuff give a chance
to cool down maybe he'll think it over [Music]
here he comes
[Music] sweet ravened
careful collateral damage it's best to have
to plan it you know whoa that's cool
that's how you take out a demon king
[Music]
living space dude thanks for helping out it
was nice to have a big gun around it was nice
not to be the kid for once when you've been
in the majors you know what I'm saying ouch
but fair oh Jesus ugh great work Titans your
determination and teamwork saved the world
and US hey guys it's Pete tonight less than
30.
carry on Titans yes yes okay that was awesome
yes the man of two teams I love it I love
it Uncle cyborg is here so good isn't that
he always said we should be together there's
got to be torture for him well you can take
the girl out of hell stuff crushed respect
absolutely [Music] jeez dude yeah look at
that I wonder what that's like to have a yammering
away in your head all day Sam that was great
Sam Leo but I like you Sammy he's the guy
from the last one yeah that's right fake to
sound you Sam Liu Sam not simulio holy man
that was incredible uh a favorite whoa
they deserve a party Teen Titans party all
those fish they killed oh oh oh what
hello that was star who is who is coming uh
Rosario Dawson's back that's right just to
Marvel's a great Batman again
I thought that was his voice I should have
called it out awesome yeah it was time to
figure it out it's a very specific his voice
as soon as I hear it now oh that's awesome
well because it's like yeah because they like
filtered it and then yeah but like jump around
those Cadence is specific I was like now that
I know it yeah it's total sense oh that's
awesome I wish I threw that out there yeah
ah well dude dude I love this one [__]
like this was everything you want out of two
teams in a movie it like that it had actual
character development like we we had said
that was one of our issues with some of the
other ones this was the opposite they let
us breathe with these characters and the characterizations
in this elseworld V thing felt like a good
blend of the comet counterpart and the thing
they built like I didn't dislike Diana or
Superman no like they worked for me uh I I
love this is definitely top three for me okay
yeah no I would say it's definitely definitely
a a see now now we're getting into that territory
where it's like oh sh is Arkham's incredible
this one those those jump out Flashpoint Flash
turtles turtles okay top five it's top five
top five yeah man this is gonna be hard to
rank now that like this many are this good
yeah it's gonna be real hard to rank yeah
well and I love the way that this used like
I feel like we do the kind of biggest dive
on Raven and and we get the sort of biggest
development on her but I love that they use
that as a means of not solely for that purpose
but like as a byproduct you know that helps
Damien like this yeah instrumental factor
in helping Damien along because he's kind
of our eye line in this whole journey like
David's been the most consistent I think yeah
and like a lot of the time you know we're
kind of at odds with Damien I feel like yeah
so uh yeah it's neat to have him be in that
position where he's still Damien he's still
very much you know got his attitude but like
it works and like we're pretty endeared to
him at this point like I really like him now
yeah oh and so and so yeah like as an eye
line uh yeah I think it makes it's good because
you can still keep growing but at the same
time yeah he is sort of your Cipher into all
these things that are happening and like I
feel like the stories they're telling are
getting bigger in a way that like only animation
can do like that would be impossible I think
live action like the cast The Demon stuff
like you'd have so much story to tell like
maybe it's like a fifth or sixth movie but
you'd have to have both teams a tablet established
separately and then so I love that like animation
can do stories like this in one because we've
only like really met Damien like of the Titans
like obviously we know the Justice League
but they weren't the lead to this no and I
thought they they did a really nice job of
having them feel present and feel necessary
to the overall picture but leaving this to
the Titans as the ones who really have to
solve and get into the nitty-gritty of what's
going on here and as I noticed like Midway
through the way they like took out Certain
Justice League members and kept certain other
ones and like the genius of not having them
like fight one Roman because that wouldn't
work with power set because then you'd undermine
Wonder Woman's power or you'd overplay the
Titans like it's important that they feel
differently power scaled and a lot of times
power scales are the first things to go in
any of these fights sure comic book movie
it's TV show like power scale is really hard
to determine who's like gonna win they did
a really good job efficiently moving those
chess pieces so it felt practical yeah absolutely
and and just the displacement of events it's
like you know when you have certain uh iterations
of the Justice League doing their thing it's
like they're kind of here to protect Earth
while we get to the bottom of this in the
other Realms and stuff like that and I love
that we had time to do bonding I love that
we had time to actually have like like this
felt like a natural story that grew into something
else like yeah you've got Damien working with
the Justice League and then he you know takes
this sort of rash uh course of action that
you know kind of even Sparks a minor debate
within the league you know Superman's like
yeah good job I mean you really gotta listen
to your dad man and then border school instead
of going back to monk Hood which he's already
done yeah now he's got to go somewhere else
so I like that they tried to solve it through
like your past is this that didn't work now
we got to try the superhero approach that
does work to a point where you're learning
new lessons and then tying it to Dick Grayson
who's often a Teen Titans member or leader
that really was cool because he's been consistently
a mentor Big Brother type so like the it's
the long game Arc with all these characters
Batman not knowing how to handle it Nightwing
trying to help the different versions of Damien's
history and then tying all of that like you
said to the grandfather with the demon parallel
with her story and that endears us to the
new Teen Titans characters we just met like
it does so much World building yeah impressively
yeah quickly yeah makes us like Diana and
Superman's relationship more which is not
something I usually dig like I don't think
then I don't ship them but with this elseworld
I like them now like they they got me now
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah like I I you know
not to slight Lois Lane but here when they
had those little romantic beats between Wonder
Woman and Superman it just felt kind of natural
to how they've drawn this University yeah
yeah I agree and it seems like conscientious
to yeah the the just the way that they carry
and portray the characters so far here and
it works like they mentioned Steve Trevor
at one point so if the world feels bigger
I like that they mentioned a character we'd
met in this case you know James Cameron um
like we get we get those little moments of
connectivity without having to like waste
screen time and like this for an hour and
20 did so much and still gave us time like
at the carnival like I love how much time
they took to endear us to these characters
instead of like oh look you like them they're
teens like they they let us live with them
well and also feeling like uh I feel like
sometimes you can introduce a group or or
you know additional characters then it'll
feel like where were these guys all the other
movies whereas here it didn't I didn't have
that feeling it didn't feel like some kind
of weird contrivance had to exist so that
now is the time that we're finally meeting
like yeah it made sense to finally bring that
into the story and then meet these new characters
through that and see what progress they're
making because now especially with the more
direct involvement of the Justice League Damien's
there you could see how they might factor
in in a grander sense as you know this universe
this Animated Universe expands out and yeah
I don't think we have to see them every time
I'm excited to see them again like I think
that it's going to be fun to like kind of
weave into the tapestry yeah exactly and I
liked uh just the I mean Teen Titans tower
does feel like they are the only five people
in it oh yeah oddly that big old T is just
those folks just hanging out it's just Blue
Beetle uh what Beast Boy Raven and what's
her name what's the Starfire Starfire and
Damien now that's it Damian's new and he gets
a lot of wings because he's frankly the whole
half the team sure I love though that they
feel like they could have just been training
the whole time like you said and not involved
but now that we've met them like we get small
street level missions and then make Cosmic
missions like what Marvel had been doing phase
one through three yeah and I think Teen Titans
are going to be really important to what James
Gunn builds because of that like I think having
a a more contained team and then a big Global
team is going to be really like great live
action yeah and and this was interesting too
because I I like this is I don't have as many
I don't have many experiences with Teen Titans
material sure and you know comic books in
general there are often debates about like
you know who who are these ideally aimed at
and I feel like Teen Titans is an interesting
Prospect because I think it was I was watching
this and it hit me it struck me that this
kind of aims more directly at I would say
teens yeah in in us in a way that like I feel
like a lot of comic book stuff either skews
Kitty or adult oh 100 and this was like no
this is like four like you know the the they're
making like little semi lewd little jokes
and stuff like that and like they're talking
about stuff that teens might talk about and
it's not like overly edgy but at the same
time it's not like they're the child Titans
right right right so it's like you have this
like weird little Interline and granted it
involves more of the adult characters but
you know it's like Nightwings on this uh this
video call with Starfire and like there's
just this weird kind of like sexual tension
100 that I don't necessarily associate with
that that other sort of semi-binary that these
can fall into so like yeah there's like a
unique sort of like additional maturity even
though it's not as full on mature it's additional
immaturity yeah exactly it's like both that
Wing's got his like he's a Casanova like that's
established but the use of how they had like
the camera and stuff is very like yeah like
and I think you're right like you you still
have the adult night wing and you still have
these teens but the choice of certain things
allows for that audience to go like ah yeah
yeah and you got Beast Boy like you know with
his like it's a classic gag of like oh he
transformed no he's naked but then he's like
but I sleep naked and I'm just like this this
is like kind of weird but also Like This lends
itself to the team to the market of it and
I I think you'd like a lot of the Teen Titans
books like right now I feel like I would yeah
Cami Garcia's writing and she uh wrote like
young adult novels she wrote like Beautiful
Creatures which got adapted like she's usually
a young adult novel writes Beautiful Creatures
it's so not bad I liked it so she wrote that
and now she's at DC uh writing uh basically
it's a book series of graphic novels so each
one of them is a whole story worry and they're
not out monthly they're literally like every
six months or so they put out one and they're
like one's Raven one's Beast Boy and then
every so often there's a team up and they're
really cool because they're illustrated by
this guy Gabriel Piccolo this Brazilian artist
that's fantastic and he does these really
um it's almost anime inspired but American
cartoonist style art but then the colorist
only uses like green is the predominant color
in Beast Boy and purple is a prominent color
so there's all the colors but like it's focusing
on those colors and the new one just came
out for I forget which character but they're
on like book only on book four they're not
that far into it and like I've been interviewing
her about these books since like 2019 like
this has been a four year run for me with
this piece and like I love these characters
because I got to learn them the new modern
take through them but then George Perez one
of my favorite creators really made the Teen
Titans like he's the guy that reinvented Wonder
Woman um and brought her to like the mainstream
and then he went on to do Teen Titans and
like they're the team at DC for me maybe even
more than Justice League because it always
feels like Batman and friends or Superman
and friends like they feel like a team yeah
as opposed to like these big heroes United
yeah like they feel like a team and George
Perez like was integral to making that happen
and uh I got to do his his farewell tour uh
before he retired and then he has since passed
away unfortunately but like we got to like
travel together and like do a bunch of like
uh cons of like what the fans mean to him
and he's one of the most intimately connected
to every one of his fans like he remembers
cosplayers he like you know takes great pride
and like I invented Raven and that's one of
the most cosplayed characters I want to talk
to every Raven cosplayer and find out why
they connect like George would literally want
to know what that character meant to them
and not even like narcissistically because
he read it but like because he wanted to connect
to the person through his connection to the
character like George was such an incredible
man so uh Teen Titans have become more and
more important to me because of George because
of Cami because of like what they are to Comic
culture and I think that's a really unique
space because they're newish they're like
30 years old 20 years old yeah and it's fascinating
too like I love that I love hearing that because
in a way I feel especially like about you
know taking that time to be like why do you
why does this character of Raven especially
resonate so much with you and and I feel like
there's something about the again the target
audience the aim the the the characters that
largely Encompass this kind of story that
I feel like has like a a more direct potential
to like impact a reader or a viewer or something
like that in a way that like anything you
read impacts you and I'm sure that you know
like kids learn from Reading you know Comics
or whatever but I I don't know there's just
some kind of like specific yeah there's a
Vitality of the potential for connection there
that I think is like really special and lovely
and and so they're not hiding the teenness
it's in the it's the first word like there's
nothing to that yeah and the whole point probably
is is that along the way they're going through
growing pains and discovering life as well
as all this super stuff yeah and uh and yeah
like I love the way that that parallels here
into the fantasy because yeah like they're
dealing with demons and they got you know
problems with their parents obviously and
she is and yeah and she and Damien can kind
of understand each other based off that but
then this also branches out into like full
on hell like that's that's the other cool
thing is I really like obviously like the
Sci-Fi the crime the detective stuff that
permeates a lot of these movies but this one
was like especially like demon fantasy heavy
metal you know hellish I mean look at now
like Teen Titans Judas contract justice league
dark like I'm really excited to see where
things go like I don't know what's next but
like it's really fun that we have opened that
door you're right like we've everything so
big there's a lot of potential now and this
was 2016. so I don't know when this ends if
it's ended but we've still got like however
many years like now we've got seven years
worth of animated yeah man and a new one just
came out like this year apparently I don't
know if it's in this universe but a new DC
animated like people are raving about in 2023
fudge yeah so like we got tons uh but yeah
we've talked about this one a bit longer than
we usually do but hopefully you enjoyed because
yeah this one's in my top three to five there's
so many guys and I love Uncle cyborg at the
end dude yeah like a 19 to 20 year old cyborg
being a little too old to be a Teen Titan
but a little too young to be a Justice League
member is so perfect I love it like it's so
good that college Adrian like what am I yeah
yeah I like pizzas still though yeah you know
and I'm still committed to my Justice League
obligations but I I wanna I wanna be a cool
yeah the cool guy the big guy bring pizza
everybody likes me it's like a cyborg man
I'm not big I'm not big brother but I'm not
little brother yeah I love that for cyborg
like it's so good but yeah I got a lot out
of this one I always love doing these with
John so please leave a comment below let us
know dude these are blessed every time a lot
of times always look forward to these uh so
yeah if you want to want us to keep making
them because we want to keep making them share
this like this all the things this you know
what to do hit that notification Bell and
let us know which of these is your favorite
and if you liked Justice League versus Teen
Titans and challenge so the big two for me
or George Perez's run on Titans and Kami Garcia
and Gabriel Piccolo's run on Titans in the
comments if you've read Teen Titans recommend
me and John some Teen Titans stuff we're gonna
get him some Comics so all right dive in much
loved reject Nation we'll see you next time
for whatever next happens we we don't know
first time watch that's the point all right
we'll see you soon but before we go we gotta
give a special super sexy shout out tomorrow
Mark Leach because your name is cool it's
got strong consonants it's got Great Vowel
use it's concise I can see it being rhymed
well as also with its impact of both Mark
and leech being single syllable one two punches
just big fan of the name I just saw it I was
like hey it's cool I like it I can vouch for
that Mark who who is it I know exactly who
it is just got it hotspot yeah oh it's a good
word a little extra like the H is pronounced
in this hotspot yeah Mark Leach I hope you
have a wonderful day I know leeches get a
bad rap but they're also used medicinally
sure and sometimes they save lives and in
the greater ecosystem of Life all animals
are important so even if you don't particularly
like leeches know that it's vital to the swamp
ecosystem which is vital to the ecosystem
around it which then spreads to all life on
Earth so leeches are vital and you are vital
art Leach